I feel really lucky because to be able
to do things I've been so proud of I
mean you know Game of Thrones is a good
example of that you know you feel so
nice to do it it doesn't it's not always
the thing that you expect because you
know making you know for want of a
better word making art is is kind of
unpredictable and you never know what
you must gonna you know you have the
right intentions and you get a good
group of people together but you never
know whether it's going to turn out good
but we had a feeling when we would do it
when we when we all turned up on the
very first day and we did I read through
and it was full of well most of the cast
of the first season of Game of Thrones
who obviously aren't there anymore for
one reason or another it was it was
pretty amazing to kind of sit and I was
sitting next to Peter Vaughan and
he held my hand and he said
what eyesight is really bad and I just
want you to give me a nudge every time
my cue comes up because I've learned my
lines already and it's like and this is
our the read-through you know and it was
a circle that kind of was like a spiral
because there were so many people in
that cast of you could imagine and it
just kind of like span around around
around but it was I mean what you knew
you knew you're in something special
when when you did that read-through and
you was like wow this is exciting the
unpredictability it's certainly an
unpredictable show isn't having list and
in dramatic as well spectacular this
season we've had them the red wedding
what did he think when he saw that what
was your faith like as you're watching
it's hard because of course I knew it
was coming I'd had I'd spent
I think what when they were filming that
or when they were about to film at me
and Finn Jones were
were in Australia and New Zealand doing
some conventions and and he'd said to me
oh I just read the script of course he
couldn't show it to me no one's allowed
to take those scripts out of Belfast you
know it they've got your name on it you
know they're like serial numbered you
know so if anyone goes missing
they know who's lost it so it's like
really it's locked out but he said
they've they're doing the red wedding
and they're doing it like in the books
and I was like you are kidding me
and I also heard this story from Finn
that with Dave and Dan the creators of
the show they one of their reasons that
are over overarching reasons for doing
the series in the first place or wanting
to put it on TV was was to do the red
wedding so they that when they they read
the imagine they were very read that and
they said if we managed to put this on
television and pull it off no one will
ever have done that in a TV show because
of course that's though I mean you have
saira member things like remember 24 I
don't know if you watched it all but I
have habit Leon tour used to spend
nights of watching you know whole box
sets you know interior like that
and of course I think that started
playing with the idea that of
cliffhangers and killing of characters
unpredictably
and and although that's not the reason
people make television series because of
course George Martin hadn't written
these books many years ago
it does portray what real what the real
world is like and I think that is quite
exciting because so much fantasy is a
it's based on here's the protagonist
this man is gonna go or this woman is
gonna go on a journey and you're gonna
follow them and they're gonna meet
people and they're gonna be put in
danger but you're always going to know
that they're going to finish their quest
you know they're going to be successful
and of course real life isn't like that
at all and I think that's very exciting
but I also do have friends who after
they read the third book threw it away
and was like there is no way I'm going
to invest any more emotion in this if
that's if that is what is gonna happen
then we're like so angry about it and
this is men you know grown men crying
tears which is pretty amazing
yeah because because you know you know
all you have to do is look around here
when you have that level of dedication
to something you love
and then someone starts messing with it
like george RR martin i mean it's cruel
it's cruel but it's also makes very very
good television
thank you cruelty in your Protege on the
show eyre it's one of the few stocks
left standing isn't she if you were if
you could go pop back into the show and
give us an advice what would your advice
be to our future season don't trust
anyone
but I I think that's you know I think
that the beauty of
of Arya's character is that
despite everything she remembers I mean
despite not immune she's a young girl so
and the situation she is fat she finds
herself are very very extreme
and most people wouldn't be able to deal
with them anyway but I think what's
really lovely and of course I say this
anyway is that she does and there was a
reason why she meets Serio and why he
teaches her what he teaches her because
that stays with her and it it informs
everything she does and so it makes her
stronger and it makes her able to deal
with it so I mean we don't even you
haven't seen the half of where she's
gonna go and but it it's it's it's going
to be an amazing journey when she starts
going on her journey on I don't think
it's a spoiler to say that she's itching
for revenge because that's where she's
heading I mean I think that's everything
about her is about that and at the
moment it feels very frustrating because
she ducked she can't but she will
Sandra's already said that she sees a
darkness in her hasn't she foe so and
and you know that darkness is a black
core which is you know a young girl
who's had her childhood taken away and
her family taken away and with every
every
every bruise every bit of damage it
makes that little dark core harder and
stronger so yeah so anyway oh there is
no advice the advice was all given in
the beginning
we'd everyone would like to see Serio
back and we live at home we live in home
because we didn't see him die on screen
did we
so what do you think I mean one of the
chances do you think we'll ever see
Syria again Oh
and
it's I can't talk about it but the
you know it's kind of like it's like
Star Wars it's like when obi-wan Kenobi
says if you strike me I will become more
powerful than you could possibly make
you know I paraphrase sorry George Lucas
it's that kind of thing it's like you
don't see obi-wan kenobe die you just
see him disappear and so so that's kind
of not what's important the important
thing is is his presence resonates and
and it's surprised to me because you
know I didn't I didn't have a lot of
screen time I mean I put my heart and
soul into it and because I knew I mean
you know it's hard to avoid the fact
that you know that he's a fans favorite
from the books and I also was very aware
that I wasn't very much like the way
he's described in the books either so
although that didn't ever influence me
because I just did it as any other you
know approaching any other character
it in the back of your mind is kind of
there you understand that
and so I feel very flattered and very
grateful and very humbled that most of
the fans majority of the fans really
really liked it and thought I did a good
job so so I mean that you know I that's
that's an amazing thing and so it's it
and from a fans point of view it's a
shame that you don't have more
characters like that in the series but
it's not that kind of serious you know
it's not gonna always give you what you
want it's gonna tease you and it's going
to keep you hooked but but but as the
Rolling Stones once said you don't get
what you want you get what you need and
although I don't think you kind of need
the red wedding do you because
ultimately you go but who's gonna who's
gonna kick the lannisters who's getting
what what's now what's going to happen
but of course that's the great thing you
don't know
we spoke to the activist jaqen H'ghar
recently tumblr shooter and which makes
me think what do you think of the theory
that cereal and jacket are one and the
same I mean I I kind of like the theory
I mean that there is exciting is it's
it's it's great to imagine that I mean
it is fantasy anything can happen and
the fact that he is a faceless man and a
and and an assassin and has
extraordinary powers maybe who knows I
mean no one knows and in a way maybe
that question will never ever be
answered or it'll be answered in a
different way I imagine it re aware end
up in Bravos at some point and we'll use
the coin so so everything's to play for
it's also the fact that as the the
storytelling becomes more complex in the
books
it will need to be unraveled a little
bit for the TV show and that's happening
already you know it has to kind of it
has to tell its story in the medium that
is that it that it that it lives in
which is TV and and things have to
change
so who knows I mean I think I think
everything is possible
huger lights see on the throne at the
end of the day
I think it's not going to be anyone
obvious I don't think it's gonna be
Danny I don't think it's gonna be John I
don't think it's gonna be
anyone that we think I think it will be
a really it might be character we
haven't seen yet it also for my money it
could be
it could be Lord Varys because I think
he probably knows more about what's
going on than anyone else
I mean who it would be a pretty amazing
be pretty spectacular wouldn't it
unexpected I think it will be someone
unexpected I think I think I mean come
on so far what have you learnt to expect
exactly so I think if he follows that
through George follows that through it
will be a surprise about striking deaths
we've seen on the show who's who stood
out for you who wins best dance for you
mister I mean jewelry getting it in the
eye was pretty spectacular
amazing death oh it's got it's got to go
it's you know no one no one gets killed
quite like Harry Lloyd with the golden
crown in the first season I don't think
anyone quite gets that kind of death
that is pretty spectacular and I
remember him saying to me when he was
about to filming he was he was kind of
doing some research about so what
exactly would happen to me if molten
gold was poured on my head how would I
die
and we kind of had a bit of a discussion
about yeah would I mean how long would
you live what would you what would you
be you know it's like it's quite Makar
but of course as actors we can't help
but do that I've got to die I'm having
this done to me
I mean it's alright if you because we do
that if you get stabbed then of course
you ask where do I get stabbed what
happens
how long is you know we what we do that
because we're we like details and we're
perfectionists
but but that was quite a funny
discussion but yeah I think that's the
best
you